good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's take
your brother to work day oh look there
you are right in the entryway so you
walk in first thing you see is the crash
course posters and some foreign editions
of The Fault in Our Stars and then you
see Danica's Mac with its Wiggly eyes
and Danica herself hi Danica this area's
for the visitors we don't have Danica
works on crash course she does all those
chalkboard drawings that are so
excellent and also the Mental Floss set
then you come to our printer room where
Wil Wheaton and Felicia Day have the
place of honor and then you spin around
and well go it's Meredith doesn't want
to be on TV today
Meredith writes Romano floss but more
importantly is the CEO of the Swindon
Town sweet leaf roofers and then we come
to my office oh hi there buster scared
of sheep this is my couch this is the
lazy boy where I've written at least
parts of every single one of my books
and this is the treadmill desk where I
have taken 360 whole steps today oh and
what assigned pail a jersey that says to
Jay green dftba good luck they like what
this is the television with this women
totally poopers come to life and this is
a painting by Sarah so Hank before Sarah
I started dating I actually bought that
painting from her and then months later
when she came over to my apartment for
the first time while we were dating I
was like a look I framed your beautiful
painting and she said yeah that's upside
down sometimes people ask me for
romantic advice my advice hang at your
future girlfriends painting right-side
up for God's sakes
I also keep all my foreign editions of
The Fault in Our Stars here like dust
chicks at least I'm Muse over a turf or
eller Sonora Explorer or jag fine
tashkent a teen cruise Raja to fail hey
then of course there's quad Nassim weena
no state welcome thread actually took
French and the ones I have no way of you
and pretending to know how to attempt
also in my office we have Leonardo's
Leonardo but most importantly we have
this beautiful view of the river
including Canada geese I used to say
Canadian geese Hank but then Canadians
informed me politely that that is
incorrect
these don't have a nationality they said
thank you for mentioning Canada baby
ducks baby ducks baby ducks duckies then
we go down the hall and we have the
kitchen featuring artwork by my lovely
son Henry green as well as posters
available now at dftba.com we have to
keep all the Clif bars in here because
mice here is the tiger who does all the
dishes thanks tiger this is apparently
the jar where we keep all the action
figures you know so they don't get out
and recap
this is the room where we shoot Mental
Floss where Stan and Mark also work
there's the Mental Floss set marks the
producer and director of the metal house
channel say hi mark and Stan of course
is working on crash course as he always
is hi since this is an episode of cribs
I got to show you what's in our fridge
mostly soda and some beer and apples
good job everybody
also Hank I have a theory that you'll
find mustard in any refrigerator and
sure enough even though we have nothing
to mustard mustard so like I wanted you
to see the office because one you've
showed me yours and two I wanted you to
be able to meet all of the nice people
who actually make crash course and
Mental Floss and the swirly poopers
happen this is particularly important
because soon I will be on paternity
leave but the things that we make here
will continue to be made even though I
will not be in the office by the way I
just noticed that I the pizza me red
why's that
yeah I'm gonna go down here by the thing
that isn't a mustache so I think the
yetis do to have a baby on June 1st but
it might happen earlier because you know
that's that's the way with babies so
hopefully you'll see me next Tuesday but
I will definitely see you on Friday
dftba